all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back yes we are we're
continuing our coverage of getting
caught up on x-men and we're picking up
with cable now here's the thing this
cable story is fun it's amazing i
absolutely love this cable story and and
to be honest with you guys i've always
kind of loved the cable stories more
recently with the younger cable as
opposed to the older cable mostly
because i read the older cable for so
long i just kind of got tired of reading
him
this grizzled old man who just kind of
ends up in some weird escapades and
stuff i will say the cable and deadpool
series was amazing but nonetheless so
what this does is it picks up in the
aftermath of young cable basically
defeating uh wolverine in the quarry
right the quarry is kind of the testing
right where everything goes down and
mutants can face off against each other
different things like that in all
honesty it makes perfect sense that
young cable would beat wolverine i mean
old cable would crush wolverine young
cable's enough to hold his own against
wolverine right just kind of the
experience and so on because he comes
from a war-torn age right comes from the
future where basically it's non-stop war
and survival of the fittest where
apocalypse had basically conquered
everything but in the midst of all this
he's actually met by the arrival of a
young mutant named curse who basically
says that that curse and a friend had
essentially kind of gone too close to a
territory where the monsters dwell right
which is kind of a sort of off-limits
place for young mutants that only adults
are really allowed to go there but the
cool thing about this is that it focuses
on you know them arriving there and then
this giant you know lion thing just kind
of runs away and there's not a whole lot
to speak of here it's kind of like you
know cable like you know get him out of
here and he kind of gets overwhelmed a
little bit and you know this this
younger mutants talking about how it's
experiencing pain and all that kind of
stuff and so what ends up happening is
that once this you know really once
cable's almost kind of incapacitated and
armor comes to his aid then he realizes
the pain this mutant was talking about
was not some kind of spiritual or
emotional pain it was a literal pain
right there's a thing stuck in its foot
and so what ends up happening is they
basically topple this this giant you
know monster thing and cable pulls
whatever's stuck only to find out that
it's basically a sword and as soon as
that happens he's met by this kind of
surge of psychic energy and then
basically passes out and he ends up
having this vision of what is a space
knight now space knights are really
really cool concepts right the
galadorian space knights these are
really awesome rom is the most popular
of all the space knights but i'm pretty
sure marvel doesn't own the rights to
rom anymore the idea behind this is that
the space knights were at one point
humans and the way it was done is it was
kind of a badge of honor to a degree a
person could have their consciousness
put in a cybernetic body and so
basically it would be a human brain in a
robotic body where they'd basically be a
cyborg and they would go forward as
protectors now the space knights were
wildly capable and they were pretty
powerful for quite some time during the
events of annihilation conquest they
were basically taken over by ultron when
he tried to conquer the universe and
then you go into what is basically the
war of the builders during jonathan
hickman's avengers and new avengers
where the world of the galadorian space
nights the planet galador itself was
totally destroyed so for the most part
there aren't really any space nights
anymore but for this particular guy he
ended up stumbling across what was
basically earth on the nation of oracle
before it split between arako and krakow
in the distant past and ended up coming
across this giant lion thing and then in
the fight of course this guy was
destroyed but his sword was stuck in the
foot of the lion and it's been there
basically ever since now on the surface
it's like okay cool whatever a sword
right this takes place before the events
of ten of swords so that's why it's here
is because it'll go on to be an
important part of the ten of swords
event but the reason why this is so
important is because what you actually
end up doing is transitioning to a place
off earth right basically the museum of
lost civilizations and you've got three
space knights who are there all of which
basically activate they kind of kick
into existence and then move forward
right they were largely believed to have
been dead because they had just kind of
been found floating out there and then
they were just you know seem to be shut
down but once they activate that's when
they basically take off and start be
lining towards earth now something else
that goes on here and this is something
i want to kind of throw out there it's
it's kind of an on running plot thread
kind of a lower plot thread something
that'll be explored later on it's
basically a mutant baby went missing
right and you end up finding out this
mutant baby was basically stolen by what
were essentially the neighbors who were
part of the order of x right the the uh
i guess the group and humanity a kind of
cult that basically worships mutants
believing they can become mutants they
see mutants as gods and they see they do
all kinds of crazy stuff sacrifices
things like that they carve an x onto
their face so that's kind of it you know
going on with with that whole thing not
a whole lot going there cable kind of
joins the investigation for a little bit
um and then you actually end up having
this instance where cyclops follows up
after nathan to meet with a couple of
the cops this is a cool moment normally
we would ignore this but it's kind of a
cool moment the reason why is because
after he's done talking to these cops
and they leave emma frost comes storming
in right and she's mad and the reason
why is because basically cable's banging
all the stepford cuckoos he's dating
them all
the staff for kakoos are basically
clones of demon frost so imagine if you
were dating like six emma frost and
that's basically what he's doing right
but at the same time they're also kind
of messing with cable a little bit right
but emma frost kind of chastises cyclops
a little bit and it's like look you know
make sure he doesn't break their hearts
but if basically if he wants to get with
all my daughters sure right just you
know let that thing out it's kind of
it's kind of weird as i say that it's
kind of weird and a little messed up
right but the important thing behind
this is that once you pick back up with
with younger cable again in their
investigations one of the things that
ends up happening is their hunt for you
know this this young girl and so on he
actually ends up taking s me who's the
step for kaku at the time who's this
girlfriend uh he ends up taking her
basically to to the house and they're
kind of investigating and she picks up
on a couple of things and then the the
galdurian space nights arrive out of
nowhere blow the place up knock him
unconscious and then leave right i end
up taking uh cable and esme with him and
then take them basically to the north
pole and that's when you get this really
interesting situation right where cable
himself has never really encountered the
galadorian space nights or any variation
of them before and truth to tell most
people haven't right most members of the
superhero community have never really
encountered space nights some have but
it's usually only the space-faring ones
right when iron man was part of the
guardians of the galaxy richard ryder
nova right like peter quill is star-lord
there's only a precious few whenever the
x-men have taken off into space and
encountered them but most people have
never met them right they fought
alongside them maybe a couple times but
by and large most folks aren't really
aware of these guys existence and the
big question they have here is how is
cable able to wield the the light of
galador as they call it right this sword
that has the power to restore the
galadorian home world and so that's when
you end up finding out where cable kind
of tries to bargain with them for a
minute that's when you end up finding
out their intention they can't really
bring back their world in the
traditional sense instead they're going
to terraform earth it'll take millennia
for it to happen but they're going to
terraform the earth and they're going to
annihilate anybody who stands in their
way now in reality these guys have no
idea what they're doing right these
galadorian nights these these guys have
no clue what they're doing like you're
talking about a world with that has at
least five people that i can count on
one hand who can alter reality on a
universal scale these guys aren't
stopping anything but for the sake of
the story
these guys are convinced they can and
that's when cable actually chimes in and
says wait a minute wait a minute you
guys said you can't restore your world
and they said yes he's like but what if
i told you you could they said that's
not possible we would need a time
machine and so ultimately what we end up
realizing here is that younger cable
intends to grab the time travel device
of his older cable counterpart right his
older self and then give that to those
guys so they can travel back to their
own history and basically save their
world during the conflict of the
builders now the funny thing about this
and what cable doesn't even really know
here is that's never going to succeed
right even cable was not part of
hickman's avengers a new avengers run he
wasn't there during the battle of you
know with the builders and everything
where the avengers were basically
fleeing for their lives and the only way
they could win was by basically
releasing the annihilation wave right
like just basically the force of energy
to almost destroy the entirety of the
universe they have to release that in
order to win nonetheless the question
they have is where's old cable buried at
right and so once they get the location
they end up realizing that basically old
cable's body's missing and then they end
up seeing what is basically a bag that
had mexico food in it right staten
island's finest mexican cuisine and you
guys know what that means where there's
cable there's chimichangas and where
there's chimichangas there's deadpool
so they end up tracking down deadpool
who of course in his own stories is now
the king of staten island which is
pretty amazing and it's kind of funny
because remember cable and deadpool have
a very lengthy history together i mean
their history goes all the way back to
the first introduction of deadpool and
marvel comics who was initially a
mercenary and then ultimately they ended
up forming a friendship which was like a
buddy cop comic one of the best comics
marvel ever released it was absolutely
hilarious i loved cable and deadpool but
nonetheless but because there's a
history there it makes sense the
deadpool would actually steal the body
of his best friend and then give it a
proper burial as opposed to it just
being dropped off in in you know some
field somewhere or some some cemetery
somewhere to basically be forgotten and
so it's kind of this funny thing because
young cable despises deadpool and
deadpool's like you know your hatred
it's a good start but you can hate me so
much more man you gotta try better
i love seeing that right like deadpool
deadpool's one of those characters i
could take him in small doses sometimes
i absolutely despise how he's written
and other times i think he's hilarious
this is one of those times where i think
he's hilarious
because i guess jerry dugan just has a
great way of writing deadpool but
ultimately he ends up taking you know
cable and the galadorians and and uh s
me and kind of takes them to where
cable's buried and initially you think
the whole thing is supposed to be some
kind of big tune right because they're
literally walking down like this stone
corridor so he's like you know like
behind this you know if you're if you're
ready for this right behind this is
where you're buried only to find out
it's like an amazing room right there's
like pictures of hot girls on the wall
and like his guns or like it's like
literally spray painted my guns
there's like there's like space invaders
you know and like like just arcades and
like a big pool table which actually
contains cable himself but it's like the
best place to have your tomb at you know
what i mean like it's the most cable
place ever it's absolutely awesome and
so one of the funny things is like like
deadpool's like okay cool so you know if
we're gonna do this we gotta play some
pool and whoever whoever wins ends up
getting the body so he's like i'm gonna
put my balls on your face cable and then
cable's just like wow and this like
smashes the glass right and then like
snatches up the arm and then basically
just leaves
just ends up walking away now as far as
what goes on here with these space
nights this is one of the cool things
because jerry dugan actually shifts up a
lot of the stuff that we're familiar
with and what he basically says here is
that under normal circumstances
galadorian space nights were honorable
people who had their brains put in
machine bodies so they could be what was
in effect eternal protectors of their
race i mean they wouldn't really last
for eternity but much longer than their
mortal bodies would normally last what
you also ended up finding is that there
was a dark side to the galadorian mythos
and what you had were basically the dark
galadorian knights these were guys who
were criminals they were guys who broke
laws different things like that
murderers and so on and so forth thieves
and what would happen is that they would
basically be conscripted they would have
their brains forcefully removed from
their bodies and then put in space not
space night suits and then they would
have to go forward as members of the
galadorian space night community the
difference is that they would tell them
once you basically complete your task
then you'll be given a full pardon the
reality is that once they completed
whatever their objective was supposed to
be they'd be brought back decommissioned
and their brains would be destroyed so
it's a pretty shady thing to do right a
pretty terrible thing to do now some of
these galadorian knights didn't realize
what was going on right some of these
dark galadorians didn't know what was
happening and they would hope that maybe
there was some kind of circumstance that
led to some of those guys being
decommissioned and their circumstance
would be different which it never was
some of the other guys like these three
uh tark brock and kron they actually
bailed out they they abandoned galador
in its entirety instead what they were
doing is they were constantly on the
hunt for the for the light of gallador
the sword of galador the biggest problem
here is that during this time because of
the fact that so much time had passed
and because they knew that they would
kind of have to stay in stasis for
prolonged periods of time so basically
they would hunt for 10 years sleep for a
thousand years hunt for 10 years sleep
for a thousand years different things
like that all under the auspices that
because the universe is going to last
for an exceedingly long amount of time
they've basically got plenty of time to
find the sword that during the time when
they were sleeping galador was destroyed
during the battle with the builders and
that's why these guys are here right
that's why they're here because they
were basically in stasis and hidden away
not only that the crazy thing about that
is it's not just these three there's
actually others there's lots of others
all of whom are basically recalled here
under the pretense that they'll be given
time travel technology by cable and
they'll be given the ability to go back
in time now in all honesty because
they'd be basically given free reign of
the time stream they would most likely
go back to the earliest days of the
galadorian empire conquer it and then
make themselves rulers and then rebuild
the whole thing in their own image but
the cool thing about this is that as
cable is basically opening this arm of
his older self and kind of analyzing it
the whole thought here is we need to
sabotage the time machine right like we
need to destroy these guys we can't just
let these guys go back in time because
who knows what might happen right we
can't give villains access to the time
stream because god only knows what
they'll do he's like so maybe there's
something that i can do some way that i
can sabotage this so he closes it opens
it back up and there's a bomb in place
of what was the time travel device and
that's one of the cool things that goes
on is because what you end up realizing
here is that in the future when younger
cable had destroyed his older self that
the way this played out is that his
older self realized that this bomb was
going to be needed at some point in time
right old cable knew his destruction at
the hands of his younger self was
inevitable there was not going to be any
way to stop it and so in order to allow
that to happen or in order to ensure his
younger self survives to grow up and
become his older self he basically
replaces time travel device with a bomb
and that's why when younger cable killed
older cable older cable didn't just body
slide he didn't just teleport away which
is what he would normally do right body
slide by one to hq and then just
disappear and live to fight another day
instead he had to die in order to ensure
his younger self could live and that's
what younger cable realizes and so with
this bomb basically being activated and
being hidden away these guys not knowing
what's going on they start to realize
like hey like our sensors are picking up
some kind of plutonium and cable's like
no no no no it's good guys uh time
travel devices need a source of
plutonium and they're like we've been
deceived like they immediately attack
cable
[Laughter]
they immediately got it for them the
whole time the bombs going off right the
curculin gate's been opened by s me to
basically give them a way to leave
because they're quite literally stranded
out in the middle of nowhere and of
course cable uses his telekinesis to
summon the sword back to himself leave
these guys stranded and as the bomb goes
off they're all basically destroyed
cable keeps the sword and passes through
the cochon gate to go back to krakowa
again and so it's kind of a funny thing
because when they land there of course
emma frost is waiting on him and then
like cable's like okay cool it was
awesome hanging out asked me it was a
cool date uh tell phoebe that i'm
excited to see her tomorrow because i'm
basically banging you and all your
sisters but uh but yeah you know let me
let me know and then emma frost was like
i'm watching you
[Laughter]
so here's the thing like once cable gets
back home
everything's kind of cool right
everything sort of calms down you got
him talking to cyclops and his dad and
so on and so forth and they're all just
kind of hanging out and doing their
thing but it's a cool little story guys
i loved it man now the thing about this
this goes directly into the ten of
swords event right which is how it
explains that cable got this sword in
the first place and then following this
of course we'll probably go into uh
cable volume 2 which is post tennis
swords which is pretty cool but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace